just gets stronger every day the bond
Blake Shelton is a family man that's a
no-brainer for mayor a source tells ET
the 43 year old country singer loves
spending time with his girlfriend Gwen
Stefani's son he's like my bestie
Blake enjoys going to the movies as a
family and spending time with 13 year
old Kingston 10 year old Zuma and six
year old Apollo Blake taught Gwen's boys
how to horseback ride and loves doing
outdoorsy activities like camping
boating and fishing quote when and Blake
do so many fun activities with the boys
and Blake pleased with them like a big
kid and cares for them like they're his
own when she loves riding and she loves
horses and it's actually it's so funny
that people are so shocked by that
the source also confirmed the couple who
have been together since 2015 may be
head-over-heels in love but when it
comes to saying I do
well it seems they're not feeling the
pressure because everything is going so
well in both of their lives quote they
really just don't want to rock the boat
when it happens you'll hear about it
Gwen and Blake are not only thriving in
their relationship but in their work
life as well the pair is headed back to
the voice for its 17th season and our
source reveals we'll have plenty of
playful and flirty moments to look
forward to on the show
[Applause]